But now we're going to learn a trick that would change your
answer from no to yes.
And that trick relates to features.
So far we assumed that we input our data features, x and y,
into this magic big box called support vector machine and outcome is a label.
Where label's either a blue circle or a red x.
So we're going to pick a feature that is helpful for my example here.
It's going to be x square plus y square.
Why that?
You'll see in a minute.
But I can convince you that it's easy to compute x square plus y
square from x and y.
So, now I have a three-dimensional input space.
It's hard to draw over here.
And I can run the exact same algorithm on these three
features that I previously ran on the two features.
And here's my $100,000 question.
Do support vector machines work by now?
Or put differently, is this new situation linearly separable?
By which I mean, can we find the line or a hyperplane that
separates the axes from the circles if this is now our feature space?
It's going to be a trick question.
It's a hundred thousand dollar questions which means if you get it right
I won't give you a hundred thousand dollars.
But give it a try.